do you have a device for young people
we've been talking about mathematics
quite a bit
but in terms of their journey through
education through their career choices
through life maybe middle school high
school undergrad students
how to live a life that they can be
proud of
i think if i were to give advice to
people especially young people
my advice would be to
always it sounds really corny but always
believe in yourself and know that you
can achieve because
although that sounds like obvious of
course we want kids to know that they
can achieve things i know that millions
of kids are in the school system have
been given the message they cannot do
things
and adults too
they have the idea oh i did okay in this
i went into this job because those other
things i could never have done okay in
so actually when they hear hey maybe you
could do those other things
even adults think you know
maybe i can and they go back and they
encounter this knowledge and they
relearn things and they change careers
and
amazing things happen so
for me i think that message is really
important you can learn anything
scientists try and find a limit they're
always trying to find a limit like how
much can you really learn what's the
limit to how much you can earn and they
always come away not being able to find
it people can just go further and
further and further and that is true of
people
born with brain
um you know areas of their brain that
aren't functioning well that have what
we call special needs
some of those people also go on to
develop and
do amazing things so
i think that really experiencing that
knowing that feeling not just saying it
but knowing it
deeply
you can learn anything
is um
something i wish all people would have
actually also applies when you've
achieved some level of success to what i
find
like in my life with people that love me
when you achieve success they they keep
celebrating your success and they want
you to keep doing the thing
that you were successful at as opposed
to believing in that you can do
something else something big whatever
your heart says to do right and one of
the things that i realized the value of
this
uh
you know quite recently which is sad to
say
is how important it is to seek out when
you're younger to seek out mentors to
seek out the
people
like surround yourself with people that
will believe in you yeah it's like a
little bit of is on you
it's like uh you don't get that
sometimes if you go to like grad school
you think you kind of land on a mentor
maybe you pick a mentor based on the
topic they're interested in but the
reality is the people you surround
yourself with
they're going to define
your life yeah trajectory so select
people's really true and get away from
people who don't believe you don't yeah
sometimes parents can be that they love
you deeply but they be you know they set
it's the math thing we mentioned they
might set certain
constraints on the beliefs that you have
and
so
in that if you're interested in
mathematics and your parents are not
that interested in it don't listen to
your parents on that one dimension
exactly
yeah and if people tell you can't do
things you have to
hear from other people who who believe
in you i think you're absolutely right
about that
so sad the number of people who've had
those negative messages from parents
in my limitless mind book i interviewed
quite a few people who'd been told they
couldn't do math sometimes by parents
sometimes by teachers
and
fortunately they had got other ideas at
some point in their life and
realized there was this whole world of
mathematical thinking that was open to
them
so
it's really important that people
do
connect with people who believe in them
however hard that might be to find those
people
you